hey it's me Steven again and this is my
brother Jordan and we're going to Mexico
all right people I know the videos
haven't been as regular as you'd like
them to but this event has been a long
time in the works National Center is
sending me to Mexico Cancun for the
global climate conference and Jordan is
going to be going with me what is global
climate no surprise the UN is actually
trying to downplay the summit this year
that's why you haven't heard a lot about
it since last year's was such an
incredible failure
they even credentialed me and a few
people at national center and now
they're sort of giving us the shutout we
applied months ago so it's going to be
hard to get in but we're gonna do our
best actually have an article here the
UN said that this is not an attempt at
any sort of binding agreements among
nations to reduce carbon emissions
anymore but this year rather to weave
together the elements of a solid
response to climate change what is
climate change so actually I have a list
of some of the issues that they're
probably going to go over we should go
over those we should start from the
beginning the beginning what do you mean
about the part about Mexico
No okay deforestation this is something
we're going to be they're going to be
talking about you were ferngully
not really Robin Williams played the bat
and that was a bad guy was the evil oil
slick I'm funny I thought that was
Aladdin
no he got a lot of voice work in the 90s
yeah well that was that whole thing was
that was about deforestation why would
you want to DeForest that's what we're
gonna get to the bottom of on the list
will be financial aid from industrial
nations to developing nations so that's
something you know they these people
they want folks like you know
Americans to give to it to third world
countries work who are trying to come up
in the ranks so why can't we give no no
they don't think there's been a
commitment for enough aid from developed
nations to developing nations but of
course they want all that aid to go into
things like providing green technology
only green technology and see that's a
big thing here nobody is is Pro
littering nobody wants to mess up this
planet we all want to have a clean place
to live the problem with the neo climate
change movement the Neo environmentalist
movement is that it's ultimately anti
human we can't expect these third world
countries to come into the new world in
advance for forcing them to do it in a
green way it's costly we can't make
solar and wind power work on a large
scale here in the States obviously
because they're unreliable but enlarged
because of the costs and and these folks
deserve an industrial revolution - what
I don't understand is because the world
once was cold and then it turned in it
became hot because of the climate change
and because of the dinosaurs and the
evolution and and Homo sapiens became
humans and now it's changed because of
Mexicans and that's why we're going to
Mexico so folks join us this is actually
just so you know the schedule is going
to be all off we're aiming to do a super
video afterwards but we're going to be
updating you if there's something that
goes down in Cancun that we think is
important we're gonna be doing updates
daily so be sure to check back at
national center Oregon youtube.com slash
steven crowder for exclusive content
we'll see you on the beach we're not
gonna see them on the beach because
we're gonna be working yeah
at the conference at the conference did
you get tickets so we can get in the
conference